Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一个现在正在进行的激动人心的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“追求经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
挑战中还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Mary Andrews Hi, welcome along. Let's think for our career and to get on and to do the next thing, you know, the next assistant psychologist post or the next research post or the next rung on the needs of the service um and the needs of the clients of course because it's not an easy time to be a human right now and so as a result of that you know the need for mental health services has gone through the roof now of course we don't just necessarily work in mental health services you might be working in forensic services um or you know risk management services or um you know uh neuropsychological services which is kind of mental health anyway isn't it but you know what i mean so um you know it's not easy and you know so the clients might
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。本期节目嘉宾是Mary Andrews博士。你好，欢迎收听。让我们思考一下我们的职业生涯，如何继续前进，去做下一件事，你知道，比如下一个助理心理学家职位、下一个研究职位，或者职业生涯的下一个台阶。这需要考虑到服务的需求，当然还有客户的需求，因为现在作为一个普通人并不容易。因此，对心理健康服务的需求激增。当然，我们不一定只在心理健康服务部门工作，你可能在法医服务部门，或者风险管理服务部门，又或者神经心理学服务部门工作，这其实也属于心理健康范畴，对吧？但你明白我的意思。所以，这并不容易，客户可能
not be coping they might not be coping on a waiting list and they might be phoning up regularly and you have to be on duty dealing with that you know and it's really tricky to really want to be able to run a service and to offer a service to people but when there are limitations in place it can be really tricky because we have ways that we can't you know respond as we would want to this can lead to an impact on you as a professional it can lead to you feeling pretty you know pretty stuck and pretty burned out and that might be the first of the life events which feels relevant to you um you know as an aspiring psychologist what we don't want is for you to burn out on your journey there but with these conflicting or massively high demands of the service that you work in it could happen you know and so we've got to be able to look after our
无法应对，他们可能无法在等待名单上坚持下去，他们可能会经常打电话，而你必须在值班时处理这些问题。想要运营好服务并为人们提供帮助真的很棘手，但当存在局限性时，这会变得非常困难，因为我们无法按照我们想要的方式去回应。这可能会对作为专业人士的你产生影响，让你感到非常困惑和精疲力竭。这可能是你作为准心理学家觉得与自己相关的第一件生活大事。我们不希望你在通往目标的旅途中精疲力竭，但随着你所在服务部门的冲突或极高要求，这种情况可能会发生。所以，我们必须能够照顾好我们的
mental health we've got to be able to raise a hand you know if you feel like you're not managing so well and actually it can be really useful if it leads to a period of therapy for yourself or something therapeutic because it can give you really useful insider insight into what it's like to be a client so it's not all bad and of course if it helps you feel better and helps you use different ways to um to cope with situations so that they crop up less often or less likely to crop up in future then that is a win-win you know what is not to like there um we all are thinking about trying to maximise, you know, our window of tolerance to give ourselves more jam in the sandwich to be able to cope better with life as it ebbs and flows and ebb and flow it will. So my life ebbed when my dad was unwell. And grief is another area which can crop up right in the middle of your ordinary life when you were least expecting it. And it can be incredibly derailing, as I experienced. And if you'd like to read more about that, they can feel like, you know,
心理健康。如果你觉得应付不来，必须能够举手示意。实际上，如果这能让你进行一段时间的自我治疗或类似的治疗过程，会非常有益，因为它可以让你深入了解作为客户是什么感觉。所以这并不全是坏事。当然，如果它能让你感觉更好，并帮助你使用不同的方式来应对情况，从而减少它们发生的频率或未来发生的可能性，那这就是双赢。你知道，这有什么不好呢？我们都在考虑如何最大化我们的“容忍窗口”，给自己留出更多的余地，以便在生活起伏时更好地应对，而生活注定会有起伏。当我父亲身体不适时，我的生活就陷入了低谷。悲伤是另一个可能在你最意想不到的时候出现在你平凡生活中的领域。正如我所经历的那样，它可能会让人极其崩溃。如果你想了解更多，他们可能会觉得，你知道，
it's not okay to take your foot off the gas, you know, to react or to take time off from what you're doing. But what we know is that you are going to be your best optimal self at work when you feel like you've got more jam in that sandwich, when you feel like you've got more flexibility, when you feel like you, you know, you're not really, really hurting in the moment when you're not really reeling from your own personal circumstances and what I found was that whilst my colleagues were incredibly supportive when I did return to work after my dad sadly passed away that we could try and, you know, give me cases that weren't about, you know, cancer, that weren't about dead dads, you know, in a trauma service. There's a surprising amount of kind of, you know, dead dads, unfortunately. Some, you know, have arisen through really traumatic murders, you know. So it's, you know, we tried to be as selective as possible about that, to look after me.
松懈一下是不可以的，或者从你正在做的事情中休息一下是不可以的。但我们知道，当你感觉自己有更多余地、更灵活，当你感觉自己没有在当下受到严重伤害，没有被个人境遇所困扰时，你在工作中才能达到最佳状态。我发现，当我父亲不幸去世后重返工作岗位时，尽管同事们给予了极大的支持，试图为我安排一些不涉及癌症、不涉及丧亲之痛的案例，但在创伤服务中，不幸的是，涉及丧亲之痛的案例数量惊人。有些是通过非常创伤性的谋杀案产生的。所以，我们尽量有选择性地处理这些，以照顾好我。
But my dad was called Norman, God rest him. And, you know, with the best will in the world, I couldn't have predicted that, you know, a case of someone I was working with, that someone significant in the story was called Norman, you know. And so daily when I was seeing the client, I was having to hear the word Norman. And just, you know, in terms of my own transference issues, having to just deal with that and manage that. And so it is worth thinking whether you whether you are well placed to be at
但我父亲叫Norman，愿上帝安息。尽管我怀着最好的意愿，但我无法预料到，我正在处理的一个案例中，故事中的重要人物也叫Norman。所以每天当我见到客户时，我不得不听到“Norman”这个词。就我自己的移情问题而言，我不得不去处理和应对它。所以，值得思考的是，如果你正处于
work at the moment, if you are suffering with grief, and whether you can raise that with your supervisor, or, you know, maybe rejig what you're doing, so that you're less likely to be triggered whilst you're hurting but it might be useful so I found it really helpful to have some EMDR so eye movement desensitization and reprocessing to help me with my grief and that absolutely helped me to you know feel more contained about it to stop things being so leaky. But you know, when these sucker punches happen and something really significant happens in our life, you know, you're allowed to be human. None of us are superhuman or should be thinking that we ought to be. So if you've got that in your head as the ideal, then it might just be worth
悲伤之中，你是否适合在此时工作，以及你是否可以与主管提出这一点，或者调整你的工作方式，这样你在痛苦时就不太容易被触发。但这可能很有用，我发现进行一些EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工疗法）来帮助我处理悲伤非常有帮助，这绝对帮助我感到更加克制，不再让情绪那么容易外泄。但是，当这些突如其来的打击发生，生活中发生了一些非常重大的事情时，你是被允许做一个普通人的。我们没有人是超人，也不应该认为自己应该是。所以，如果你的脑子里有那种理想化的想法，那么可能值得
having a little rethink about that another big life event can be becoming a parent and i will be back to talk with you about this um just after that break. So come and take a look It's right here in this book It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Hello, my name is Veronica Kassova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a Master's in Psychology of Mental Health. Marian recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people
重新思考一下。另一件重大的生活大事可能是成为父母，休息过后我会回来和你谈谈这个。来看看这本书，它就在这里，是《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。你好，我叫Veronica Kassova。我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在LinkedIn上建立人脉时，Marian向我推荐了《临床心理学家合集》，我必须说我非常喜欢它。它是独一无二的。它就像是一扇窗户，让我们窥见那些
on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others, but with myself too. Also not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, grow and the final results will come as a byproduct. Marianne thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf.
走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙述才能揭示的无形智慧。我在最珍视的故事中发现的一个共同点是，不仅要对他人的痛苦感同身受，也要对自己宽容。此外，不要执着于一定要成为心理学家，而是要享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品自然到来。Marianne，感谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一块真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位准心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。
Thank you. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. So, becoming a parent, this is something that I get asked reasonably often, you know, should I have a baby, you know, before I start my training? Should I have a baby during training? Is it best
谢谢。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验教训。所以来看看吧，它就在这里，是《临床心理学家合集》。它是《临床心理学家合集》。它是《临床心理学家合集》。那么，关于成为父母，这是我经常被问到的问题，你知道，我应该在开始培训之前生孩子吗？我应该在培训期间生孩子吗？最好
to wait until after training? And I think it's such a unique decision based on you, you know, based on your age, based on your gender, based on your ideals for, you know, what kind of parent you'd like to be. So I know that for me, it felt like being an attachment parent. And, you know, using principles of gentle parenting felt like they resonated with me most okay so that's you know baby wearing and breastfeeding i was a breastfeeding mama um even with children with tongue ties to overcome that um and you know bed sharing when needed um as well and actually that would have been tricky if I was trying to work um as you know aspiring psychologist at that time but you know like many things in life we do just get on know, and make the best of a situation. And actually, if you feel like the time is right for you to start a family or to expand your family, then, you know, then that might well be what you want to do. most definitely a better psychologist since becoming a parent because it's given me new insight into you know positive regard and unconditional positive regard
等到培训结束后吗？我认为这是一个基于你个人的独特决定，取决于你的年龄、性别，以及你对想成为什么样的父母的理想。我知道对我来说，成为一名依恋型父母的感觉，以及运用温和育儿的原则，最能引起我的共鸣。所以，那包括背带育儿和母乳喂养，我是一位母乳喂养的妈妈，即使孩子有舌系带需要克服，还有必要时的同床睡眠。实际上，如果我当时试图作为一名准心理学家工作，那会很棘手。但就像生活中的许多事情一样，我们只是继续前进，并充分利用这种情况。实际上，如果你觉得现在是组建家庭或扩大规模的好时机，那么这可能正是你想要的。自从成为父母后，我绝对成为了一名更好的心理学家，因为它给了我关于积极关注和无条件积极关注的新见解，
giving me new insight into love and you, difficult feelings and parenting, you know, with a partner and staying on the same team, even when you don't always agree. It's, you know, I've really learned a lot. And so it's not, I'm not suggesting that you have a child to become a better psychologist. Please don't think that's what I'm saying. But, you know, like learning to dance in the rain isn't it that you might well you know stumble across new insights and reflections that are really useful you know so um that you do make interesting talking points for interviews you know when you're demonstrating points when you're're demonstrating that you have a good real life application of theory and can weave that into your understanding about clients and to advance your skills in being an aspiring psychologist. And another common life event can be relationship breakdown. You know, when you thought someone was going to be your forever,
给了我关于爱、困难感受和育儿的新见解，比如与伴侣共同努力，即使意见不合也能保持在同一个团队中。我真的学到了很多。我并不是建议你为了成为更好的心理学家而去生孩子。请不要认为我是在这么说。但是，就像在雨中跳舞一样，你很可能会偶然发现非常有用的新见解和反思。这在面试中会成为有趣的谈话要点，当你展示你对理论有很好的现实应用，并能将其融入到你对客户的理解中，从而提升你作为准心理学家的技能时。另一个常见的生活事件是关系破裂。你知道，当你以为某人会是你永远的伴侣时，
and you hope they might be, or even if they were your just for now, you know, I absolutely, during training, spent a few days laying on a sofa, wailing because the person I thought was going to be my right now for a bit longer wasn't oh dear poor poor Marianne she was hurting she was hurting and so if you're experiencing your own heartache um you know heart goes out to you because it's not easy you know when you're trying to navigate that and while still showing up and still being present you know still trying to help clients and your staff team when actually your your world has got a bit dented so yeah you know it's important to think about who you're able to talk to about things like this you know are you well supported by your family have you got friends that you can talk to about it um even if they can't change it
你希望他们可能是，或者即使他们只是你当下的伴侣。在培训期间，我确实曾在沙发上躺了几天，嚎啕大哭，因为那个我以为会陪我走得更远的人却离开了。哦，亲爱的Marianne，她很痛苦。所以如果你正在经历自己的心碎，我为你感到难过，因为当你试图在处理这些的同时，还要继续出现、保持专注，还要试图帮助客户和员工团队，而你的世界已经有点破碎时，这并不容易。所以，思考一下你能和谁谈论这些事情很重要。你的家人支持你吗？你有可以倾诉的朋友吗？即使他们无法改变现状，
which of course we often know they can't you know but can they hear you you know and I think with relationships it can be really useful to think about you know you've already imagined you know the next stages you might already have imagined you know children or you know you might even have booked holidays or weddings or something like that and so to then alter your perception of what your life might look like in future can be tricky, can be problematic. And you can allow yourself to grieve, you know, for what you've lost. And you absolutely can grieve for things that haven't yet happened you know for things that you had imagined would happen you know it's it's taken your life in a deviation from the course that that you would have hoped for and we kind of have to hope that things might work out for the best and that's you know what what's for you doesn't pass you by but it doesn't always
我们通常知道他们做不到，但他们能倾听你吗？我认为在人际关系方面，思考一下你已经想象过的下一阶段会很有用。你可能已经想象过孩子，或者你可能甚至已经预订了假期、婚礼之类的。因此，改变你对未来生活样子的看法可能会很棘手，可能会有问题。你可以允许自己为你失去的东西感到悲伤。你绝对可以为你尚未发生的事情感到悲伤，为你想象中会发生的事情感到悲伤。它让你的生活偏离了你所希望的轨道。我们必须希望事情能朝着最好的方向发展，属于你的东西不会错过你，但这并不总是
feel that way and that's sometimes a way that we make sense of what's happening to us but doesn't necessarily help us to deal with that pain you know um doesn't get that person to change their mind or be the person you know you might be the person that's decided to end this relationship because they're not the person that you need and yet you can still grieve for that relationship and I know that another common issue for aspiring psychologists is another biggie and it's where you live so it's really common to be applying for jobs all over the country and maybe even the world you know when you're an aspiring psychologist to try and build those skills and competencies that you might be lacking you know you recognized you would benefit from you know new new skills experiences and opportunities
感觉如此。有时这是我们理解正在发生的事情的一种方式，但这并不一定能帮助我们处理那种痛苦。这并不能让那个人改变主意，或者成为你想要的那个人。你可能是决定结束这段关系的人，因为他们不是你需要的人，但你仍然可以为那段关系感到悲伤。我知道准心理学家的另一个常见问题是另一个大问题，那就是你住的地方。所以，申请全国甚至全世界的工作是非常普遍的，当你是一名准心理学家时，为了尝试建立那些你可能缺乏的技能和能力，你意识到你会从新的技能、经验和机会中受益，
so I know at any one time in sort of 2006, 2007, I think I had an interview being offered to me in Nottingham, one in the Lake District, bearing in mind I was living near Milton Keynes, and one in Birmingham. You know, that's quite a big spread offered those jobs, two of the interviews I didn't actually end up going to in the end. But if I'd been offered those, I would have considered relocating, even though I didn't know anyone there. And I know that's really common in psychology to just up sticks and go somewhere else, especially when you start training. But that takes time to to adjust to, you know, to find somewhere to live and to make sure you've got to feel safe there if you don't know the area of the country that you're going to be living in and to find new normal, you know, takes time. As well as trying to throw yourself into this new job, you're, you know, doing something pretty important, which is, you know,
所以我知道在2006年、2007年左右的某个时候，我想我曾收到过诺丁汉、湖区（考虑到我当时住在米尔顿凯恩斯附近）和伯明翰的面试邀请。你知道，这分布很广。我最终没有去参加其中两个面试。但如果我收到了那些工作邀请，我会考虑搬迁，即使我不认识那里的任何人。我知道在心理学领域，尤其是开始培训时，搬到别的地方是非常普遍的。但这需要时间来适应，找到住的地方，并确保如果你不了解你要居住的地区，你能感到安全，找到新的常态。这需要时间。除了试图投入到这份新工作中，你还在做一些非常重要的事情，那就是
settling into a new home environment. And that might be that you're renting with others and trying to, you know, get through all of that, everything that's inherent in that as well. So there are absolutely many, many different life events that can crop up on your journey to being an aspiring psychologist. So I thought it would be useful to just give you a little bit of an overview of those. And if you've got any more life events that you'd like me to talk about, just give me a shout. I do have a five day challenge coming up. So if you'd like some opportunities for free to learn about um you know building the skills and competencies to help you be the psychologist you would like to be then do check out www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash aspire.
安顿在一个新的家庭环境中。这可能是你和别人合租，并试图度过所有这些固有的困难。所以，在成为准心理学家的旅程中，绝对会有许多不同的生活事件发生。所以我认为给你一个概述会很有用。如果你还有其他想让我谈论的生活事件，尽管告诉我。我确实有一个为期五天的挑战即将到来。所以，如果你想获得一些免费的机会来学习如何建立技能和能力，帮助你成为你想成为的心理学家，请查看 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/aspire。
I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode very soon. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist, it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist
我期待很快在下一期节目中与你见面。保重。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Marianne博士的《准心理学家》。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，
I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书了。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。